>> APPARENTLY DISCOVERY IS A
VERY POPULAR SHARP WEEK PROGRAM,
IS RACIST.
THEY ALSO HURT THE FEELING OF
SHARKS.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" OUT WITH
THIS HEADLINE.
SHARK WEEK LACKS DIVERSITY,
OVERREPRESENTS MEN NAMED MIKE
AND THE REPORT HIGHLIGHTED A
STUDY AS WELL THAT CLAIMED THE
SHOW EMPHASIZES NEGATIVE
MESSAGES ABOUT SHARKS.
AND OVERWHELMINGLY FEATURED
WHITE MEN AS EXPERTS INCLUDING
SEVERAL WITH THE SAME NAME.
THAT WOULD BE MIKE.
THANKFULLY, THE SHARKS CAN'T
READ THIS.
HARRIS?
>> HARRIS: SO LET'S PUT THEM ALL
IN A SHARK TANK AND SEE --
[Laughter]
>> HARRIS: IF THEY CAN TAKE THE
FEELINGS OF THE SHARKS INTO
ACCOUNT IN THAT ENVIRONMENT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HARRIS: THAT'S IT.
I'M DONE.
>> WHAT SAY YOU?
>> I WOULD SAY IF WE FIND OUT
DISCOVERY IS ONLY HIRING MEN
NAMED MIKE, PREFERABLY MIKE, AND
MAYBE THERE IS A PROBLEM BUT
GIVE ME A BREAK.
MIKE IS SUCH A POPULAR NAME.
THERE ARE SO MANY MEN WHO LOVE
SHARKS.
THERE ARE PROBABLY MORE MEN IN
THIS PROFESSION THAN THERE ARE
WOMEN, AND HAPPEN TO BE NAMED
MIKE.
THAT WAS A VERY POPULAR NAME,
MICHAEL, WHEN WE WERE GROWING
UP.
STILL IS.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A PROBLEM
HERE.
I'M NOT OFFENDED BY THIS.
IF WE NEED MORE WOMEN IN THE
PROFESSION, FINE.
HIRE SON WOMEN TO BE ON
DISCOVERY.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
THIS IS SHARK WEEK.
DO WE REALLY CARE?
>> RAYMOND, ON THE OTHER HAND,
PEOPLE ARGUE, THE VOICES ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT, REPRESENTING
MATTERS, THERE ARE PLENTY OF
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE
FIELD THAT GREW UP WASHINGTON
SHARK WEEK THAT SAY I CAN'T
ENTER THAT FIELD BECAUSE THOSE
PEOPLE DON'T LOOK LIKE ME AND
THE REALITY IS, IN THAT
INDUSTRY, THEY ARE MOSTLY MALES,
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR AREN'T
REPRESENTED.
HOW DO YOU BALANCE THE TWO?
>> THIS WOMAN, THIS RESEARCHER,
HER NAME, BY THE WAY, IS LISA
WHITE -- NACK, PEOPLE MAY HAVE
ISSUES JUST WITH THE NAME.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOMETHING LIKE
SHARK WEEK NATURALLY MEN ARE
GOING TO BE MORE DRAWN TO
DEALING WITH SHARKS.
IT'S LIKE ME SAYING, I DID A
STUDY.
TOO MANY OF THOSE HOUSEWIVES OF
BEVERLY HILLS AND THEY ARE ALL,
YOU KNOW, AGAINST THE HUSBANDS.
OR, YOU KNOW, TOO MANY DRAG
QUEENS.
THAT'S WHAT THE SHOW IS ABOUT.
WE CAN'T TAKE ISSUE WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE NATURALLY
ATTRACTED TO THIS REALITY GENRE
OR THAT AND TRY TO MAKE A
NATIONAL CASE OF IT.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THAT ONE THERE
IS ANOTHER ONE OVER THERE.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
YOU CAN CHANGE THE CHANNEL.
>> CHANGE THE CHANNEL.
THERE IS DIVERSITY ACROSS THESE
NETWORKS.
>> YOU AND I ARE BOTH PART OF
FIELDS THAT USED TO BE
ABSOLUTELY MALE DOMINATED AND
NOW THAT RATIO HAS CHANGED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> MOST LAW SCHOOLS ARE MOSTLY
WOMEN.
I THINK THE STATS ARE CHANGING
FOR THE MEDICAL SCHOOL.
>> MEDICAL SCHOOL, 50-50.
I AGREE WITH ENSLEY, WHAT SHE
SAID.
THIS WOULD BE A STORY IF THEY
HAD EVIDENCE WHERE THEY PRODUCED
EVIDENCE SHOWING THAT BLACK,
BROWN APPLICANTS WERE BEING
DENIED FOR LESS QUALIFIED WHITE
APPLICANTS NAMED MIKE.
THAT'S THE STORY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHAT I SEEM TO FIND AS THE
ISSUE IN THIS IS THE WASTE OF
ACADEMIC FUNDING, SO THIS STUDY
CAME OUT OF ALLEGHENY COLLEGE
AND RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THE
COLLEGE.
THEY ALSO JUST GOT A $500,000
GRANT FROM HOWARD HUGHES UNDER
THE NAME OF TO FOSTER EQUITY AND
STUDENT EXPERIENCE IN THE STEM
PROGRAMS.
I DON'T KNOW, WHY DON'T WE TAKE
THAT $500,000 AND PUT IT INTO
THE STEM INNOVATION SO WE CAN
ATTEMPT TO BE ON PAR WITH CHINA.
IT'S A WASTE OF ACADEMIC FUNDS
AND IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
TAKING A SERIOUS NOTE FOR A
SECOND.
IF THE INDUSTRY IS LACKING WHY
SO MUCH FOCUS ON THE COVERAGE?
WHAT DOES IT MATTER IF SOMEONE
IS ON TV?
SHOULDN'T IT MATTER WHO HAS
ACCESS TO THE RESEARCH XWHOOSHGS
IS ABLE TO GET THE EDUCATION.
EARLIER IN THE SYSTEM RATHER
THAN WHETHER A PRODUCTION
COMPANY HAS FEATURED SOMEONE.
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I WOULD LOVE TO LEAVE IT ON A
SERIOUS NOTE BUT I DO WANT TO
TAKE IT HERE.
BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT.
BRILLIANT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HAS ANYBODY ASKED THE SHARKS
IF THEY IDENTIFY -- LIKE ARE
THERE ROUND SHARKS ON THE
INSIDE?
I JUST WANT TO KNOW.
>> CAN I SAY WHAT I WOULD SAY TO
MY DAUGHTER.
MOM, I WATCH THE SHOW.
THERE ARE NO WOMEN ON THERE, I
WOULD SAY, GO DONNING IT.
GO GET ON THAT SHOW.
>> SHOULD WE CHANGE FROM IT A
GREAT WHITE SHARK